Jason Derulo are you okay on Tuesday the
singer posted this video to Instagram
eating his corn on the cob with a little
extra Flair yeah you heard me
Flair like he put the corn on a power
drill turned it on and started chomping
away
listen quarantine has people doing all
kinds of weird stuff but this is
next-level and its seemingly didn't end
well
yeah it appears that Jason majorly
chipped his front teeth
ouch naturally that moment went viral
and caught the attention of Chrissy
Teigen who reposted the cringy clip and
jokingly referred to Jason as Jathan
duro on Instagram Jersey Shore's Mike
the situation Sorrentino hit up
Chrissy's comments writing we got a
situation while Katie Couric asked am i
the only one who can't figure out how he
did this yeah so it's not clear if he
actually chipped his teeth or if it's a
prank but it looks pretty damn real to
me Jason posted a follow-up tick-tock
hours later and he covered his mouth
while he talked about the damage
how much do you think is going to caulk
a face stop it stop lying I thought good
ugly look at me
but then he posted this tick-tock
smiling right at the camera with a full
set of pearly whites so real fake you be
the judge but this isn't Jason's only
quarantine booboo back in April he lost
a bet and had to shave his eyebrow
okay so I know we're all looking a
little rough during quarantine but word
of advice never ever put your eyebrows
on the line guys Jason shared this pic
of his bald eyebrow on Instagram writing
how long this gonna take to grow back
like I said don't mess with your brows
but all that might have been a prank too
because it appears that missing eyebrow
has grown back in record time this is
why Jason has 20 million followers on
tik-tok and 5.7 million on Instagram he
keeps us guessing yeah that and his
six-pack ABS thank you so much
in November Jason went viral for posting
a pic of himself in a swimsuit that put
his man business on full display I think
it's amazing I'm amazing look the pic
was removed by instagram for violating
its Community Guidelines so he fought
back posting the pic again this time
censoring it with a subway footlong
sandwich
now speaking of suits you were in a suit
recently on the old Graham yeah and it
was going viral did you think that
picture would warrant that sort of
reaction I promise you I didn't when I
was posting it that morning no I mean
like you just you know some people say I
was just an accidental person you know
what you're oh no I know I knew is that
it was a thirst trap picture but I
didn't I didn't think when I posted that
it was gonna be my most liked photo in
that first couple hours no I'm saying I
didn't think it was gonna like you know
take him down from the gram I didn't
think he was gonna like cause this much
third
[Music]